Cuál es la importancia de retomar estos
diálogos Bueno dialogar siempre es
interesante porque permite conversar
para negociar y llegar a acuerdos tanto
el gobierno del presidente Maduro que
está muy interesado en que le levantan
las sanciones y el gobierno de los
Estados Unidos muy interesado en
conseguir a la brevedad petróleo y gas
barato y seguro a vida cuenta de que
Rusia producto de las sanciones que
ellos y los europeos impusieron producto
de la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania ya no
puede encontrar con el suministro de
petróleo ni de gas en el caso europeo es
presidente byden con mucha astucia y con
mucho pragmatismo está intentando
negociar con el gobierno del presidente
maduro a objeto de que se reinicie las
negociaciones Solo que hay un detalle
estas negociaciones en México es con un
sector de la oposición no con toda la
oposición y este sector de la oposición
en el caso venezolano tiene
contrapartida con los partidos
judicializados por el gobierno del
presidente maduro cuya titularidad le
fue otorgada a los adversarios de estos
que van a reunirse en México Total que
demuestra con ellos una gran astucia el
presidente maduro porque en el exterior
reconoce a esta comisión o a este sector
de la oposición y en el caso venezolano
reconoce como autoridades de los
partidos políticos a otros que son
adversarios de estos hay un gran enredo
en la en la política venezolana porque
la oposición está dividida y está
dividida no solo por la astucia del
presidente maduro sino por la por los
propios errores cometidos por la
oposición en el sentido de haber
sistematizado la convocatoria a la
abstención a pesar de que muchísimos les
dijimos que ese era un camino errado y
totalmente
destructor de las posibilidades de la
oposición venezolana todas las encuestas
dicen que el presidente maduro tiene un
apoyo muy precario y sin embargo sigue
controlando todo porque todas las
instituciones le fueron regaladas
gracias a la absten
el gobierno del presidente maduro en
este caso tiene mucho que ganar porque
si le levantan las sanciones va a poder
recuperar parcialmente la economía y
avanzar en la recuperación de otros
sectores que ellos mismos destruyeron
Pero cuando la oposición controlaba la
asamblea nacional que pudo haber ayudado
o ayudado al gobierno en materia de
recuperación de servicios públicos
esenciales como la electricidad y el
agua no quiso hacerlo para que el
gobierno no ganara
rédito pero los organismos
internacionales como la corporación
animal de fomento ofrecieron recursos
para esa recuperación cosa que hay que
emprender en cualquier momento porque ya
el daño está producido Bueno y qué tanta
estabilidad y legitimidad podemos
esperar pues en estos diálogos de parte
del gobierno maduro y también de la
oposición para que las conversaciones
prosperen bueno porque quien está detrás
de ese sector de la oposición para que
esas conversaciones tengan relativo
éxito es nada más y que el gobierno de
los Estados Unidos es decir el mismo que
ha producido las sanciones que tanto
daño le están haciendo No al gobierno de
maduro sino a la población en general
entonces esa es una discusión que hay
que dar Con urgencia para que haya
salidas en el orden social y económico
para la recuperación repito de servicios
básicos desde niños que son esenciales
para el venezolano de a pie es decir en
Venezuela en este momento lo que era la
Joya de de los de los sistemas de metro
en toda América Latina en Venezuela fue
destruido por el gobierno y ahora hay
que recuperarlo no hay transporte
subterráneo no hay transporte
superficial no hay luz no hay agua no
hay un conjunto de de de sistemas
básicos que la población necesita con
absoluta urgencia
Bueno y qué papel jugará Colombia en
estos diálogos entre la oposición y el
gobierno de Venezuela la mediación y me
parece que es correcta No solamente la
del presidente Petro sino la del
presidente de Argentina y el presidente
de Francia que como ustedes vieron en la
Cumbre de Egipto se acercó a conversar
con el presidente maduro a objeto de
Buscar mecanismos de intermediación para
negociar de hecho ya se produjo una
reunión en París que conduce también a
esta digamos retoma de conversaciones en
el caso de México Dios quiera que todo
salga bien porque le conviene al país en
su conjunto porque lo que hay que frenar
es el deterioro que es muy profundo en
el caso venezolano a pesar de que en los
tiempos de la República civil como todos
sabemos Venezuela fue de los países más
prósperos de todo el hemisferio